à
mais où là
or battus peut-être bien non paul de gaz
est superbe
s'ajoutent à l'eau tout le long du rhin
à ton corps est autant d'énergie à
l'aveuglé là parce que c'est vrai
alors tu es content super sympa
desquelles des coups dont 37 ans dont la
sortie sur le rouge cela vous pensez
qu'on veut leur faire ou pas ensemble
européen dance when encore quel repas de
rue avant de se faire je le soulier d'or
je verrais pas pourquoi on le fait ça ok
le plongeon
là on se dit que si longtemps nié les
faits semblent un peu tu veux car dans
leur antre un peu d'ordre dans le dos de
taille peut être dans le noir doit lever
deux rondes noires capsule bastolaer de
toute forme de la même chose
je montrais pas dans le paysage derrière
nous avons passé pour ça mais qui est
très compétent tu vois il veut refaire
un tour à droite tu peux refaire encore
un tour à droite parce que tu as toute
la vie derrière et il a derrière
vas-y sors de ton truc super bowl à
d'incroyables tanguy la résistance est à
retourner
tu vas y retourner tu vas y retourner
vas-y s'il te plaît vas-y vas-y
maintenant en hauteur voilà très large
très large avec toute la vue hier rien
forcer beau parent prenant que l'alcool
au delà du rocher y voilà et on sent
en passant comme ça
parmi eux
ok
beau non